court and K joining the game absolutely
very exciting we had we had Chris just a
couple of weeks ago we've announced this
morning we've got Courtney and kloe
joining probably just in time for the
holidays uh and the game's in the top 10
grow scene still so I think there's
probably a lot of uh investor Miss
perception around how long this game is
going to stay in the top 10 grossing how
involved have Courtney and Khloe been
and Chris I mean I know you talked a lot
about how much Kim cares about this but
what what is it like to work with the
rest of the Kardashian Clan well Kim's
certainly on point for all of this uh
and probably her momager is uh second on
point so they're all approving their
their images and there's a lot of
iteration on how people look and how
they'll be involved um but Kim's
actually thankfully been doing a lot of
this for us uh directly you've got a
contract with Kim until
2019 what if she is no longer Popular by
then I mean investors do seem to be
worried sure I think that's probably uh
unfounded uh if you look at the history
of the Kardashian that that she will not
be popular in 2019 obviously we've taken
a big bet on that although the deal
terms they've been publicly disclosed
and they're really quite reasonable if
you look at the size of minimum
guarantees versus royalties that she's
been paid and I think her Brand's
actually just getting started if you
look at International markets she's just
popular right now in a few of them and
she's scratching the surface I think tip
of the iceberg of where she'll probably
be in 3 four five years time you've also
said you're you're paying significant
royalties on this game I mean how much
is it costing you to have the
Kardashians involved here and and you're
also looking at the most significantly
profitable year for glue in seven years
does this weigh on those profits no it's
actually this is the misperception I
think of all misperceptions right now on
the glue stock is that it's actually
enhancing profitability really quite
significantly uh ebit off for glue in Q3
was $15 million it's guided to be
another big quarter for us in Q4 and Kim
has been a big piece of that in both
quarters so on a blended basis royalties
are running at something like 12% of
total glue revenues but it's going down
in the percentage terms in Q4 because
Kim will be a lower percentage of
revenues in Q4 than Q3 what do you think
investors are worried about them because
your C I know your CFO has sold millions
of dollars worth of his stock well I I
would never look at sort of selling so
much as buying right so people sell for
a lot of reasons there's retirement
planning there's buying houses getting
divorces all sorts of reasons people
might sell stock but they only buy for
one reason in the last two weeks I
bought some stock just yesterday or
rather Friday two more of our directors
bought stock so I think the disjuncture
between glue profitability and stock
price performance has never been greater
in our history actually so why should we
be betting on the Kardashians
essentially because this has become a a
huge driver of of growth for you it's
been a big driver but there's actually
four games in the top 100 grossing for
us Kim's number nine Racing Rivals is
number 33 deer hunters 57 Contra killer
75 so we're a franchise company and
actually all four of our big franchises
I think are going to do well for for the
next year if not more philosophical
gaming question we've been talking a lot
about take 2's latest version of Grand
Theft Auto which allows you to have sex
with prostitutes and then kill them they
say that it is Art what do you say I
mean it's a different kind of gaming
than the games that you guys are making
but it's sort of part of this world well
I think free speech is free speech on
the one hand on the other hand you know
we're a mobile game Focus company we
partner closely with Apple and Google we
have a board member in common with
Google and we want our titles to be
featured prominently so I don't think
you're going to have a path to featured
success with these storefront uh
Partners if you if you go over that line
we keep our games 12 plus and sometimes
sort of G so to speak um so you know
ultimately if you look at a deer hunter
or a contra killer game they have really
quite little violence compared to a
console game majority of glue portfolio
revenues are indeed not coming from from
violence certainly to not extent so you
know things like racing r rivals in the
Kardashian game they're very very family
friendly so you've got Kim you've got
Courtney Chloe and Chris I know she's
very protective of North how do you
build out the glue sure Empire aside
from getting North on board well step
one for us as we've always said is make
sure that the Kim Kardashian Hollywood
game has a 5-year plus run we're adding
family members we keep adding other
locations right so wherever Kim is in
the world whatever she's up to this game
is more entwined in her life there's
opportunities for other Hollywood
Partners potentially so if you look at
Kim's World in its entirety there's
other people she interact with which we
could probably add into the game so look
out for that next year like
Who TV you know we'll shout about that
next time possibly U there's also
obviously room for other celebrity games
so we're in discussions with other big
names big social followers who want to
frankly make what we call Trans media
experiences make a game that mirrors
your real world in the virtual space and
there's other people I think will be
exciting that will come out next year